[Music]
if you learn to love the thing you hate
you might find a big gift in it and for
me i didn't like sales i hated it i
tried selling when i was 17 years old
lost a job 18 i tried again part time
during the summer lost the job 19 years
old lost the job i had had five
experiences in sales and hated every one
of all different industries i just kept
moving industries thinking okay it'll be
different this would be easy to sell i
hated sales i hated talking to people i
particularly hated the beginning the
rapport building you know i'm not good
at breaking ice like ryan secco he can
talk to anybody i can't do that i can't
go into a room i could speak to 35 000
people but i can't go into a room and
start warming it up it's just
uncomfortable so the point i'm trying to
make is when i was 25 the only job i
could get was a sales job and i said hey
you got to decide that you're going to
get good at this even if you hate it
because you can't lose another job it
would have been my sixth firing and i'm
like i cannot lose another job i did by
the way get fired from that place but
they never got rid of me because they
kept selling yeah so every time they
fired me i'd be i'd go back and sell
something they'd be like hey
so you know i went from hating sales to
committing to it to becoming now known
as like one of the greatest living sales
people on the planet so in the things
you hate yeah like where does the hate
come from like the things that you hate
the things that just grind you out like
you're just bug you there's probably if
you just stay with it and look just move
to the side a little bit and look behind
it there might be some great gifts need
motivation watch the top 10 with believe
nation hey it's evan carmichael and i
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
grant cardone and my take on his top 10
rules for success enjoy
rule number two reboot yourself what is
the the mindset you would share with
anyone who's 40 50 or 60 and be above
who hasn't
accomplished what they want yet
what would you say to them
based on what you've learned after 50.
you know i used to tell myself i would
never have anything to contribute to the
world until i was 50.
because i'm very immature i've always
been described as a rough diamond like
like rough around the edges
abrasive
not much of a filter you know i i am i
mean i know everything that people say
negative about me for every one thing
every the public has i i know i know
every one of them
there's nothing anybody ever says about
me that surprises me i'm like yeah i
know that
like you guys don't think i know that i
live with me every day late
i did actually did not think i would
have anything to contribute worthwhile
until i was 50 years old
and uh that was about the time the
economic uh collapse was the great
recession and i was so lost in that
financially i didn't understand i was
actually being farmed right there i was
being matured i was being prepared for
what whatever's going on in my life
right now
really the the creation of grant cardone
has happened in the last 10 or 12 years
not
not before that
the grant cardone people know today is
being being developed right now
and i would just tell people that are
older like
dude you're going to have more energy
later unless you don't
you're going to have more genius later
unless you refuse to
you're going to have the ability to
influence more unless you refuse to
influence
and age has got nothing to do with the
game like nobody really knows my age
like
i was 50 years old when i was in pueblo
i told everybody i'm 50 years old my
name is louis curtis i have two kids
beautiful two kids i got a wife named
ava
had made up names for the kids i had to
make up all that story
and we live in l.a and i hate it
because if i told people i was me in
miami
uh if anybody went and searched it
and started doing you know images like
people do all that stuff today
i know
so um i would just tell people man you
look i look at people that are 80 years
old i'm like dude i got 20 years left
you know how much damage i could do in
20 years i know guys are in great shape
uh dolly parton i mean she's still
hammering she never did nine to five
she made some money on a song called
nine to five
you know but she's been doing five to
nine for for years so i just think
people can get better if they want to or
they can get worse you're either gonna
decay
or you're gonna reboot yourself over and
over again rule number three seek for
possibilities i have a couple businesses
this year we'll do 150 million dollars
my real estate we have 2.5 billion
dollars worth of real estate that we own
that produces cash flow almost 10 000
units that that
2200 bucks a month do the math on that
things are very good at our place
and i'm like
why don't you become a real estate agent
okay average real estate agent makes
what 25 000 bucks a year or something
25 000 a year okay right something like
that
it's sad
it's sad and i want to talk to you about
the finances right now okay
somebody said about not chasing
squirrels i think she was talking about
chasing other opportunities is that
right okay but also you guys need to
think about not chasing squirrels that
don't get your opportunity here because
they're squirrels they're gathering nuts
like oh i can't i can't i don't want to
put signs up i'm like dude move on
you need people i need people in my life
that are heavily financially motivated
i hear everybody talking about their
wives and their kids and and oh my god
life is to be lived you cannot live on
this planet without money folks
okay nowhere can you go and buy
something the yacht
the experience the weekend i would look
for people that are financially
motivated that want to make more money
and that understand that financial
illiteracy is what's hanging people up
from their dreams
you got people hey what do you want to
do well i want my time off what are you
going to do with time off you ain't got
any money
the hell man you want to wanna know the
cause of depression
too much time and too little money
get me a job get me a mission get me
something to do give me possibility give
me a payoff rule number four look for
cash flow what do you look for when
you're making a real estate investment
if it's anywhere in the world or yeah
yeah yeah what are the key things i look
for cash flow first number one i look
for cash flow because cash flow will
allow me to keep a piece of property
first through the cycles
so number one i want to be paid for
something i do not speculate on real
estate i've never lost a penny investing
in real estate i've been doing this for
35 years
number one i want cash flow number two i
want a great location that's
irreplaceable i care less about the
kitchens and the living rooms
and the exterior the paint the roof i
care nothing about those all those
things can be changed the location can
never be changed and the third thing i
want to know when i buy a piece of real
estate is
who can i sell this to exactly
okay so i should know who i'm exiting
with i should literally know who the
next buyer will be before i purchase the
property
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five play big 2008 2009 was
tough for you just like it was for a lot
of people what was the lesson you
learned then that prepared you for 2020
that you when the recession hit you said
okay i know exactly what to do based on
that pain in 2008. yeah well i was so
disappointed with myself then like
i had not put my family in a position to
to
flourish and prosper
because of suppression you know the tide
goes out you don't have a boat shame on
you right and i didn't have a boat dude
i mean i had i looked good i looked good
until it happened you got a suit you had
the car i thought i was good i thought i
was good but i was too small small small
always gets hurt
and that that was my big wake-up call in
2008. i didn't have enough assets i
didn't have enough money i my business
was too small my customer base was too
small uh i was too relying on too few
verticals
this was the creation of 10x
i blamed no one in 2008 9 and 10. i was
like okay i'm in
i got myself in [ __ ]
this is not about the mortgage crisis
it's not about the builders it's not
about the strippers they got 17 loans
this is about me i was in this polish i
was in this fear i was i let my family
and myself down
nothing was happening to me
and the most important thing is
i was not in a position to take
advantage of it that's the thing that
pissed me off
and so i told elena i said the next time
this happens
dude we're going to freaking rock
and then covid had happened and coveted
i was shooting the tv show and my
company would have the best years ever
had wow i wasn't even here
we we bought more assets this year than
we bought the year before we raised more
money this year than the year before it
um you know when when when lehman
collapsed in 2008 i had 50 million
dollars worth of debt i told elaine i
said the next time the [ __ ] hits the fan
i might have a billion dollars worth of
debt i know i told i said i'm gonna have
a half a billion dollars worth of debt
we had a 1.2 billion dollars worth of
debt when covid hit rule number six
change your game
i made a launch out i was in a middle
class family raised by a single mother
we had a roof over our head three meals
a day uh i had all the love i could do
but god we had no money
and when you don't have money you have
fear
when you don't have the right vehicle
when you're in a vehicle you're you're
working real estate and the most you can
make is three percent they're going to
chop you you know they're going to chop
you you know the seller's going to
cut you up 3
you got me two million over asking
and you want three six percent and i
gotta split it with my wife
right
how many of you get chopped up
you're getting chopped up because you're
not professional enough yet
when they're still asking for your fees
they are saying hey you are still not
the player that i that deserves a full
fee
so you got to change your game now man
particularly with inventory problems
that you have right now you're going to
continue to have this inventory problem
folks this is not going away housing
prices over the next decade will not go
down they will go up they will continue
to go up you're looking in a rear view
mirror thinking about what oh i should
have bought everything
because you should have by the way
but you didn't
because you didn't sell enough to have
enough to buy enough
right and you were sitting in the market
you were sitting in the market how many
times have you said this is a good deal
how many of you remember said that
before this is a good deal
why don't you buy it
oh because you can't
because you didn't
say you didn't do enough to put yourself
in your family in a situation where you
could and that's what happened to me in
2010. i had not done enough i had three
successful businesses all three of them
got cut off because
of of this mortgage thing rule number
seven get rid of limiting beliefs it
took me a long time to understand that i
had limiting beliefs especially when i
was doing well so when i started making
80 and 90 000 a year in sales this is
many many years ago that's like 270 000
today in an industry by the way where
the top producers were 40 000 the
limiting beliefs that i had at that time
and then even when i was making a
million dollars a year were the ones
when i was making money you know when
you're not making any money it's clear
you got a limiting belief you know
you're making 30 grand a year and that's
all you can make no matter how good you
are no matter how much you smile no
matter how much service you provide no
matter how early you get there how late
you stay and you still make 30. you know
there's a limiting belief because
everything would indicate you should be
paid more when you're making a million
dollars a year you start thinking i
don't have any limiting beliefs so the
way to handle that is you need to study
people that have created massive amounts
this is exactly what the 10x rule was
about create massive amounts in the
millionaire booklet talks about earning
money keeping money and multiplying
money this is what the great sales
people don't do i know great salespeople
that have never figured out how to
multiply money i know salespeople that
are so good like i'm like that guy is
probably a better sales person than me
but he's still broke he's broke because
he made his money didn't know how to
keep it
or he kept it didn't know how to
multiply it how much you earn is
eliminated believe how you keep it where
you keep it is the limiting belief if
you have money in the bank or equity in
your house or you have a retirement
account you have a limiting belief about
money you're saving for a rainy day you
have equity in your home waiting to pay
it off in 30 years completely ridiculous
no no high performance person needs to
worry about paying their house off you
should rent where you live
own
stuff that other people pay you for okay
and just rent where you live and be
mobile and the third thing is you know
planning for having cash sit in an
account just sitting dead in an account
or in your wall or underneath your bed
or in your safe or the vault wherever it
is but what about an emergency if your
money's in the bank and the internet
goes down you won't be getting your
money out there's no getting the money
if you got it underneath your bed what
what for like some of you are storing
money in gold gold is a limiting money
belief you're like oh my god the world's
going to come to an end gold will not
help you out of the end of the world
scenarios you should make a whole list
of all the limiting beliefs that you
have around money number one number two
you should most importantly make a list
of limiting actions
not limiting beliefs because your
beliefs are turning into actions how you
save money how you spend money how you
invest money diversification is also a
limiting belief okay now i know a lot of
people recommend diversification
especially the people on wall street
that benefit from you diversifying the
most
they don't want you all eggs in one
basket but if you study the super
wealthy they took stakes once they got
super rich then they're like okay i'll
own the railroads the banks
and all the grocery stores rule number
eight think big what was the first thing
you ever sold when you were a young
young grand first thing that i the young
grant cardone the first thing i ever
sold was uh i think it was clothes was
it closed yeah i think i was selling i
was in a clothing store
and i earned six percent on a tie okay
socks and t-shirts
um and at that time i think a tie cost
like i don't know maybe
20 bucks so i'd make like 12 cents or
something wow
i was bumped up about it too i was
actually excited i had minimum wage
minimum wage back then was like 1.85
and i'd get a little you know
70 cent
commission
great yeah what was your favorite that
great what was your first uh real estate
investment my first real estate
investment was a single family home it
was 78 000 i put 3 000 down i thought it
was a genius move
i used 3 000 to buy 78 000 i i thought
okay this is the best thing i i don't
even see how this can be
and uh you know that today would
probably here because it's 20 down now
would probably cost him 15 000 but
that's still a good deal 15 000 i could
leverage a 80 000 piece of real estate
obviously you can't buy anything here
for 80 000.
um more like a million dollars maybe out
in the country yeah but not in the city
you're looking look if
yeah but but if you could figure out
just if you could just make the
transition the biggest mistake i made in
real estate was i didn't buy enough real
estate i should have bought more real
estate i should have bought it more
aggressively i should have paid more i
should have bought in better locations
because i was thinking too small i was
thinking about the three thousand
dollars i had rather than how could i go
raise the money yeah so look there's no
shortage of money there's a there's a
shard of crate a shortage of creativity
and commitment but there's no shortage
of money so you know you got million
dollar properties here how can i go get
gather some family members and some
friends put 200 grand together and own a
piece of real estate that we know is
going to be worth more money in the
future rule number nine use debt to
invest consumer debt is terrible debt
suicide debt that's that's credit card
debt lamborghini buying the lamborghini
on debt uh like if you're going to buy
lamborghini at lease it for 24 months if
you can't afford the 24 months you can't
afford the lambo debt for clothes
christmas gifts
i mean it's stupid it's stupid to borrow
money for for for this santa claus for
your kids i know i know people are going
to hate that message that's why there's
so many people dislike you know they
they just don't like that
it's stupid to go in debt if you want to
do it and uh and for for fun or for
whatever then that's okay but you mean
you're not investing in
a potential greater future no
now if i if i borrow money for santa
claus that's one thing if i borrow money
for to to invest to
to buy to invest in in a piece of real
estate for my kids you know i mean i
know which one's going to work yeah if
you just follow the tax write-offs
you'll know the right thing to do
i can't write off santa i can write off
the real estate
right so um
yeah bad debt is anything that i have to
then pay the interest rate on
good debt is i made an investment and my
consumer or my tenant is going to pay my
debt that's powerful so you're trying
you're trying to get more debt you
probably have more debt with me than you
even know
like like because of the investments
you've made with me you have debt you
have good debt
you just don't really know it your
accountant does though because because
we're sending them the k1 at the end of
the year that's why when we send you a
check you don't pay income on that check
that's nice very nice
so you you look at your return but you
know whatever i paid you last year
but that is
non-taxable income to you
because of the debt that we have because
of the debt
yeah exactly on the asset exactly and
rule number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus clips is get a source
of income michelangelo okay michelangelo
he didn't want to pope but he didn't
want to paint this 16 chapel right dude
the the po the uh the pope said yeah i
understand you don't want to bro start
painting
look what he did yeah yeah right so i
don't know if that's you know i'm just
saying like
i know artists that do what they love
they can't even feed themselves
you know they they love their they love
their wife too or they love their
husband but you can't take care of them
you love your parents but you can't take
care of them so it's it's just not true
if you just love something if you only
do the things you love there might not
even be any money in it
like you could love horses but
you should have lived like maybe 1400
years ago
yeah
and so falconry we had a falconry guy
out here yesterday teaching us about the
birds and the history of it two hours he
spent with us it was freaking
unbelievable
you know but
you know it's a very niche yeah right
yeah
you know 1400 years ago everybody had a
bird yeah you know that was your that
was the lamborghini of the day today
that's probably not
you could love it but you're not going
to feed your family with it
you need massive massive levels of
activity going into 2021
because the other brokers remember
there's great brokers and there's
everybody else there's great agents and
everybody else you got to decide to be
in this top five percent
and do not even look at anything the
other 95 of the people do i know this is
a cruel hard message but they're not
paying me
if they were paying me i could give you
a soft loving message
okay i don't care if you guys like me or
not what i care about is whether you
like
whether you like you or not more at the
end of this year
than you did at the beginning of the
year because that's the target man i
gotta love myself i gotta like me
okay i'm not trying to produce for the
rest of the world i'm trying to produce
for me i'm not even trying to produce
for my kids and my wife
yeah they're beneficiaries
but look if i can please me
if i can hit my if i could shock myself
okay would i be able to take care of my
wife and kids
my kids man they're lucky to be alone
for the ride
little freeloaders i think that there's
a shortage of real men on this planet i
think most men are
i mean frankly just [ __ ]
you know i don't know if your audience
can handle that word but
look man if you can't get your money
right
something's wrong
if you can't take care of your family
you got to ask yourself how much of a
man are you like for me that identifies
me as a man my ability to take care of
my family i don't just mean financially
but i do mean financially right
my job as a
as head of household
is to take care of the economics of the
household you know the word economy if
you look it up in the dictionary it
comes from managing a household it had
nothing to do with the business
it was about managing the household so
if you go back a thousand years we've
been managing households my job as a man
is to provide a place where it's warm
a place where we can sleep a place where
we're protected place where there's food
right not money right i need to be able
to take care of the family shelter food
clothing
and i need to have some fun my family
wants to have fun we want to have
experiences so i need to provide a
secure environment for them so they're
not think bad things aren't just
happening
and so so men need to like bone up man
like the government can't take care of
you bone up you know this yeah bone up
get strong right right right
so get a get a backbone
and take care of your family and quit
blaming the government
are
making excuses that your neighbor or
the economy or whatever conditions look
i have i've had some terrible conditions
in my life
from the age of uh 15 till 25 it was
awful for me
10 years nobody would want to go through
the 10 years
that i went through do some people have
it worse than i did probably but i don't
want to do those 10 those 10 years were
terrible for me as degrading as a human
being can experience
drugs yeah drugs but mostly just so many
bad choices so many bad people
you know so so much self
uh self uh deprivation and and and just
a lack of self-esteem and self-love
for myself because of a lot of bad
choices
so i understand what goes on through for
a person when they're making bad choices
and and and people just need to man up
you know bone up the women need to do
the same thing by the way yeah women are
stronger than men today
oh
look i hate pain any kind of pain women
can handle 10 times the pain i can
handle my job is to get 8 billion people
to know me if enough people know me
they'll buy from me how many believe
that
i'm not going to be i'm not going to be
a slave to one person or one vertical or
one niche or one partnership i have you
guys have the whole world at your access
the whole world and by the way if you
can't get south korea to talk about you
you can't get south indiana
or indianapolis to talk about you
there's people in korea that are tied to
hawaii that are tied to colombia that
know somebody in indiana and it can just
bang out like that
and i also believe that if i could get
enough people to know me in one market i
think that there's something that
actually happens
i think if you could out f
if you could get if you could push out
enough frequency about your brand
yourself your ideas to enough people
that you hit some critical mass i don't
know if any of you agree with this but i
think there's a spiritual component to
where if you can vibrate through enough
all of a sudden other people start
thinking i know that dude
i've said this for years if i can get
enough people a very small percentage of
the population to know me i think the
other 99 become convinced they know me
um do you think
that somebody needs to reach a certain
like status before but no no no you do
not need to reach certain status you
need to assume the status now you need
to have the altitude right now to be the
professional that says hey i know about
fitness
i know about plumbing i know about
trucks just take whatever you guys are
certain about and post out of it and by
the way if you're not certain about it
write an article about what your
uncertainty's costing you you're going
to figure out every possible angle but
none of that's going to happen until you
guys make a decision to blow up
and none of the blow up gonna happen
until you make a decision that money is
important because if you got people
around you saying money's not important
ain't no way you're gonna do this stuff
because it hurts
when nobody sees your stuff
number three number three study two
multi-millionaires do not
take heed to this do not study a
millionaire once a person becomes a
millionaire the first thing they do
unfortunately is go into conservation to
protect the million study
multi-millionaires study people that
have consistently developed and proven
because the tens or twenties or thirties
or hundreds of millions of dollars that
they've accumulated that they have the
right practice the right discipline and
they're still expanding you don't need
22 mentors
study two people deep
that have gotten it right study two
people so deep rather than 20 people
shallow i promise you'll make a
difference if you get a chance to spend
three days with anybody that's
accumulated 30 40 50 100 million dollars
i'll promise you it's a game changer so
put that on your bucket list i'm gonna
spend three days with a
multi-millionaire in an environment
where i can learn from them it will be a
game changer for you and also limit your
study to two people not 22 people that
will create you from having conflictive
uh data and content and information
nobody's ever done it by themselves
so the old the the entrepreneur that's
uh popular right now is the guy that
works from home
he's a solopreneur
um i don't know if you have this term we
have yeah yeah
it's a complete misnomer nobody has ever
existed on this planet and done
something successful by themselves
no it's never happened
so there's no there's zero examples of
anybody that's done any i mean jesus had
had 12 of course had 12 guys he was
rolling with right alexander the great
had an army uh genghis khan had a had
like you're not doing this thing by
yourself nobody does like for too long i
ran by myself
and and it took a lot of energy you know
it took a lot of energy it takes more
energy running by yourself
uh ryan secco here the captain the pilot
and and the real estate dude he always
says dude it's just more fun to run with
the team and he's right yeah you know
henry ford people said henry ford made
the car out of his garage i said yeah
but the company didn't make
they didn't make
to the
yeah yeah so uh mark zuckerberg said you
know facebook was made out of a dorm
facebook was made when he moved to
silicon valley and started a company
steve jobs steve and and the the the
other dude what was the dude
yeah yeah they built apple you know
supposedly built it out of their garage
yeah no nobody knew about apple until he
moved the company and started and and
added employees so nobody's doing
anything great by themselves you guys
would take days off it's my day off you
ain't entitled to a day off
[Music]
why do you think you should have
wednesdays off or thursdays or or you
can't work saturdays or
sunday sunday you can't work on a sunday
okay are you and you got people around
you telling you not to work on sunday we
have to have a little life balance dude
how can you have life balance when you
broke
how can you have life balance at a
holiday inn when the people next door
keep you up all night
that ain't life balance that's not even
a vacation
right the whole trip how many have been
on the trip you did the budget trip
included the free breakfast
you did it on miles
and you wish you didn't even go how many
been on that trip before
maybe you don't do the trip maybe you're
not entitled to a trip this year maybe
you're not ready to trip
[Music]
that's what elena and i did for 10 years
the sacrifice the sacrifice today we'll
sacrifice this week we'll sacrifice this
month we'll sacrifice
this year we'll sacrifice
so one day maybe we don't have to
compromise
every week we talk about our finances
what do we do this week how much do we
make where are we going what are we
spending okay the moment i say hey no
more jackets no more
stop it she'll stop it
so that we can one day we can one day
spend whatever we want okay there
there is should come a time where you
guys should be able to spend whatever
you want but most people are spending
what they can afford
now only to find out later they can
never have anything they don't
understand how to make their money
multiply and most people don't
understand there is a sacrifice phase we
went through the sacrifice phase where
there was years of just cut off
everything and we weren't saving for a
landing
for the rainbow that's right y'all need
to save for the rainbow you need to you
see we didn't go on a vacation for 13
years yeah i've been saving for this
stuff
i did i wasn't saving for vacations i
was saving so i could bank into real
estate so i could go to sleep at night
and even if i had a bad night of sleep
and had to get up three or four times
i'm like dang i'm making money in my
sleep even if i'm unhappy i'm like i'm
making money in my sleep man see that's
the goal that you and your wife need to
have let's make money when we go to
turks and caicos or when we go to st
bart's or when we go to cali let's go
waste some money later in our life
maybe you say hey i'm going to sacrifice
today
so i don't have to compromise in the
future
i'm uh 20 years old and contracting here
in michigan um my biggest question is
you know gain credibility in business
being young in an industry
yeah so good question i'm glad you said
new to the industry not because you're
only 20 years old
you got it you got to get you got to
become you got to become the uh the
expert buddy i don't i don't know how to
tell you this any other way you got to
become
you got to become the expert in the room
you got to know more than everybody else
you got to be like people say oh if
you're in if you're in a room and you're
the smartest guy in the room you're in
the wrong room you go in a room dude you
need to be the smartest guy in the room
you need to be the guy in the room that
sucks the oxygen out of the room
so elon
elon musk walks in a room and
everybody's like don't get up to the
office but doing my best just trying to
build a report and uh no no don't don't
don't try to build report dude you got
you got to become an expert at your deal
like if you're milking cows you need to
become the freaking guy that knows every
freaking angle on a on a cows
okay
like
michigan
right gosh
okay so dude take take like like
you're 20 years old bro spend the next
four or five years becoming an expert in
your field
study it breathe it
live in it don't drink the kool-aid
do backstrokes in it i don't do
businesses that don't serve my life
so the real estate
it's just what i'm doing every day right
it's the speaking
it it just all fits for me so i need a
lot of action but they all work like
like my hand i move my pinky and all the
other fingers removed so if i move this
business it it touches these businesses
the businesses are all connected they're
interconnected they're a bit connected
right so if i move one we came here to
do a speaking gig okay but we stacked
this interview this is part of my
business right my our online presence is
dependent upon me being willing to do
this in addition we don't go anyplace
for one thing
so the guy that tells you focus on one
business we do why don't we have one
finger
why don't i just have one thing great
right
so boom i got i got notice i got five
fingers and i got two hands
i had a i had a girlfriend but this was
before i was married she says you want
your cake and you want to eat it too and
i said yeah
why have a cake
if you can't eat it okay so my my mom
used to tell me you need to focus on one
thing at a time i'm like five fingers
five feet two hands
okay so i want my hands and all a bunch
of pies
i just want to be sure i want to eat
that pie okay i want to eat that meal
right because i think a lot of people
have their hands
sorry i think a lot of people have their
hands and stuff they don't really want
to eat the meal do you guys just rub her
neck your whole life you know you ever
been driving down the road there's a
wreck on the side and everybody's like
oh my god why is all the traffic stopped
there's only one person with a flat tire
on the side of the road right
everybody's stopping to see what the
hell happened over there you rub a neck
in your life and not getting where you
want to go okay because everything's a
distraction some people call it
schizophrenia like my friend kathleen
but it's not really schizophrenia it's a
lack of focus
number nine
make hard decisions fast people say man
you're a hard man you're a tough dude
okay look you got to make hard decisions
fast when things get tough they say the
tough get going truth is when things get
tough
the successful make hard decisions
quickly that's why super successful
people are often misunderstood they're
willing to make
hard decisions that often don't make
them look good and for which they're
later judged the truth is for you to be
financially successful you will have to
make very very difficult decisions when
you do
make them fast my mom used to say if
you're walking through hell son
pick it up go fast i want you to walk
away understanding that some of you have
businesses
that are just not good businesses
[Music]
and if you have a business that's no
good
you can't build the empire you want
why do i need money what don't i know
about money why are people struggling
with money you should ask yourself these
questions why are you coming up short
on money
is it what you know or what you don't
know
how many of you know this saying
knowledge is
okay how many of you agree with that
how many agree knowledge is power so
look if you don't have money and you
have knowledge maybe you have the wrong
knowledge
i hated sales i hated it
five i was in five sales jobs
was a disaster at all of them
hated absolutely hated it
um you're the master of sales i i am i
embrace the things i hate why why were
you bad at it why did you hate it i
didn't know well i was bad at it because
nobody teaches anybody how to be good at
sales
you know so
i didn't know how to communicate to
people it didn't know how to shake your
hand didn't know how to build rapport
i'm i'm
i'm honest enough that i'm not gonna lie
to people so the stuff i was being
taught to do i didn't like
you know they ask a question you ask
them a question slimy dude
you know i have enough integrity and
ethics
[Music]
that when you tell me okay we're not
manipulating but don't answer their
question i'm like well dude
that's just that that is manipulation
and that's why i think a lot of people
don't like sales because of what's been
taught for a hundred years blueprints
outdated you got there it was not it was
always wrong okay
it was wrong and it's why i believe it's
why sales people have such a high
turnover why so few people want to be
called salespeople
i mean you go through herod's down there
you can't find a salesperson in the
whole joint
you think sales people are ostracized in
america oh dude i'm here it's terrible
here i mean really we've had books where
seller be sold we had to change some of
the language in the book for it to be in
bookshelves here
so like the word pressure can't be in
there
persistence can't be in there
like there's things you get laws you
guys actually have here that like
go to europe it gets one step worse you
know because it's as a whole i'm ashamed
of money and i don't want to talk you
know we can talk about that too but so
the sales blooper you get in they give
it to you it's not working for you it
doesn't make sense for you and you're
like i gotta i gotta make my own well
what happened was was i was in a sales
job
i i i got to college to i got a college
degree in accounting and because you
thought it would teach you about money
and it didn't yeah so so i i end up in
the sales job it's only a job
and so i hate it right so i'll go to the
treatment center i come back out of the
treatment center i threw myself into it
because it's the only thing i had
i i still had so little self-esteem that
there was no way i was gonna go try to
get another job yeah right and i was
terrified of using drugs again so i'm
like i went back the the place where i
was working they took me back and i just
i threw myself into it and it's
interesting when you commit to something
little gifts
just start automatically showing up it's
a phenomenal thing
so so i threw my a guy walks up he gives
me a it was a little cassette tape he's
like hey i heard this i thought you
might like it
i listened to it i was like oh my god
there's a way to sell stuff
i didn't know there was actually
something you could do
i listened to it i called the 800 number
i said what else do you have
and the guy said we've got a program for
three thousand dollars it's 25 years ago
so it's like 10 grand
so i don't i said i'll call you back
call my mom i said i need to borrow
three grand
first money i ever bought outside of
college she gave me the three grand
um and changed my career i've been here
five years you guys don't know me you
know why
i didn't let you know me
[Music]
if you don't know me you won't flow me
right or wrong
so my job is to make sure i'm known
today today it's easier than it's ever
been before that's why i'm a guy that's
using
social media to get known
takes courage to stand up here it takes
courage to get known it takes courage to
build a brand it takes courage to build
a youtube channel and an instagram and a
facebook i'm 60 years old i don't know
anything about instagram except that i
got 900 000 people that follow me every
day like a religion
you ask what church do you go to i go to
the church of grant cardone
okay what's my name
my name is grant cardone what's my name
my name cause you didn't know this is
for the people that didn't know my name
is
grant cardone let me hear it
okay my job my job my first job your
first job is to make sure people know
your damn name cause if they don't know
your name they i don't care what you
sell you're a nurse you work at
mcdonald's you're a bellman i don't care
what you do you're parking cars it don't
matter if i don't know who you are
it doesn't matter how good you are how
clean you are okay it doesn't matter
your values don't matter nothing matters
if i don't know you
so i don't believe in this concept about
balancing business in life i've never
all the people that talk about it yeah
don't have don't have the very thing
they're trying to get probably yeah so
you're constantly balancing something
you understand that i think so totally
totally so so if you just like what i do
is i just push into everything
right i push into everything as hard as
i can
and and again the goal is life it's not
the business
it's my life right business is part of
my life so having fun is part of my life
my spiritual part is part of my life so
i'm going to push everything into that
thing that i'm working on the 10x the
10x thing was about i'm pushing
like if if it's
if it's in the business i'm going to
push as hard as i can on that
and my kids are with me my wife's with
me she they're with me so they're
they're having the experience of this
push
then we turn around we push over here oh
we want to help charities out and we
push 10x
into that direction well it's just it
just blows out the edges
of the life right so that we get to have
a bigger experience as opposed to okay
now i need to
put this here
and manage this part right now
which means when i'm doing this when i'm
finding time just for my kids i'm
abandoning all these other things and my
life gets smaller all the commitment
stuff oh you got to be committed oh you
got to be committed we always talk to my
trainer about this you got to be
committed yep treat this there's only
one thing you really have to do
because the commitment is not going to
come until you do this other thing
the thing that has got me through
everything
got me to where i'm at today the thing
that changed everything was me just
taking action
just doing it i mean i know that's that
old nike saying right just do it
man even if you don't feel like it even
if you're not committed even if you're
not getting any gains
even if you're not winning i talk about
this in the rules of success
show up
just take action make the call
knock on the door
send out the email
bug people if you have to you know until
you get good and it doesn't sound like
bugging anymore it's just the
professional knows how to bug people
without bugging them
so look
just take action even if you don't feel
like it money is so simple
okay anybody got a hundred dollar bill
give me a hundred dollars sir
give this man a big hand for having some
money
okay
i just had an idea i said i wonder [ __ ]
i ain't got any money on them
i had an idea now i'm gonna teach you a
lesson right now that'll make you rich
if you freaking get it okay number one
i want some money
number two
i need to ask somebody if they got 100.
number three
i need to get the money
it's no more complicated than that
i didn't go manufacture something i
didn't build a business plan
i didn't create a product i had an idea
the the the length of time between your
idea and the money will determine
whether or not you're successful
the length of time
between the idea
and the monetization big word for
get the money
the the distance between the idea and
the money
will determine whether you take off or
not
why do we make so many excuses i think
that we are like
excuses making machines yeah yeah like
if i miss a deal we we do a lot of real
estate deals so if i miss a deal i'm
always going to what did i do wrong in
that deal first response for me is what
did i do wrong in that deal that they
didn't pick me what did i do wrong that
i didn't get that deal what did we do
wrong that we didn't hit our number
there like i'm never saying it's not
blaming somebody well i don't have
control when i'm blame
i want control
so
even if they are to blame right
i want control i'm not gonna assign you
blame
if you hit my car i'm gonna i'm gonna
say what did i do wrong
what did i do that allowed you to hit my
car
i did something
so even in the most dumb dumb like i i
ended up in a lawsuit where a guy
basically
found something
sued me for it
i didn't do anything to this dude
my immediate response was what did i do
to create that frivolous
situation he was a criminal total
criminal sued me for 60 million bucks
he just sued me because he he thought he
could get something from it but but i
did something and the reason i want to
assume that
what the cause i want to be the cause
point is because if i assume that
position even though i didn't really do
anything
then i can control what i did i can't
control what another person does but i
can spend time and energy controlling
what i do the company is only as great
as the driver is number two
does the dude have a bunch of fuel you
know what fuel is see this plane right
here this plane's no good no matter how
good this plane is if there's no fuel
play no good
plane don't go anyplace without fuel
neither does a company i know guys that
have great companies but they're out of
fuel
they're just not
they're not going to use it they're
drivers they were drivers they used to
drive they got fuel in a tank but three
they won't use it they're not going to
press because somebody's on their neck
right now saying conserve your money a
lot of rich people this happens to a lot
of rich people people get rich they go
from the middle to rich and never get
wealthy and when the wealthy it becomes
impossible to get wealthy like the
rockefellers or the people that were
talking about the duponts the morgans
the uh who the vanderbilts because
because the cardinal the cod don'ts
because they get satisfied with wealthy
i'm sorry with rich and they never get
wealthy wealthy is
generational money grant died i
guarantee you my grandkids will be
talking about me that's a bam
right there dude
that dude
number four dude you got to have a
future like the future i'm interested in
and and by the way i'm gonna go back to
the new world order boys and girls the
the illuminati the masons whoever they
are these people think about futures you
guys don't they're thinking about
generations that's what the japanese do
the japanese they think about future
generations they're not thinking about
right now how about the muslims they're
thinking about lifetimes from now how
many heard this before people buy from
people they like
no no no people buy from people they
know okay if you're taking notes people
buy from people they know period they
don't buy the best product they don't
buy the cheapest product people buy from
people they know
because if you don't know me
trust will not happen
that's why i rolled up on damon and said
hey how about i put you in the plane and
i fly you to provide you to vegas same
dude's telling me i was stupid behind a
plane
i said dude come on
what's wrong with you man you spent too
much time on a street corner selling
hats
that bird that bird that bird is what
got me in front of you dj little man
oh yeah yeah you're right man
and then he says now i'd have gone with
you anyway you would not have got on
jetblue with me
don't lie man i know you're the people
shark but don't lie
what am i call you up hey damon i bought
a ticket for us on southwest
you want to fly to vegas with me and we
can eat peanuts
he wouldn't have gone with me how many
agree he would not have gone with me
come on man he might be the people's job
but he ain't stupid he's like hey i
ain't doing that right or wrong
he said to me what's the fuel in that
jet cost i said bro you you're thinking
small bro
he's like what do you mean what's it
cost what's the damn fuel in the jet
cost
i said i don't know
why don't you know i said because the
jet ain't no good without fuel
well i think the the idea of
knocking on doors
you know
talking to people yeah like these are
the skills that are not taught in the
schools this is what goes back to your
question about the school system failing
the
the the required skills
i need a client
like if you simplify the thing that
people like about what we do is we
simplify the business process
i need to make a contact
how can i do that
like how can i just simply
if i'm doing if i'm a cameraman and i
want more work you know how do i
knock on a door or make a phone call get
in front of someone
it's so hard impress them
you know if i go to heron's right here
i'll see how many people don't have that
skill i walk in that i don't even get
hello
you know i don't get hello how you doing
great to have you here appreciate you
being here it's so nice for you to drop
by thanks for coming into cartier i mean
it's a 3 million ring over there i went
in there the other day i can't even get
anybody to show me anything
i'm like how much is the ring
you know they kind of look at me right
can you show it to me do you mind
showing it to me
he showed it to me told me how much it
was and i leave you didn't show me a
second ring or third ring or fourth ring
so those are the skills that people need
right how do i
how do i interact with people
communicate yeah the middle class adds
and subtracts
and and clearly the middle class never
figured out
how to do what the super wealthy do like
it's almost like
hundreds of millions of people in
america stop math at adding and
subtracting and never got to the
multiplication part
because the super wealthy are
multipliers oh by the way time
energy and money they multiply all of
them they're like like i have time i
want to make more time how do i do that
you learned how to add you learned how
to subtract but that's not what the ross
charles did that's not what the
rockefellers did that's not what the
duponts did
they multipliers
they're multipliers
this
by the way 10x
is a gateway drug to the illuminati
i'm telling you right now the 10x was
basically a secret kind of passage
for all of you that want the new world
order for all of you interested in the
invisible rich for the masons out there
that you're like i know there's 13
families i know there's a deal with the
federal reserve i know there's world
monarchs don't you know that 10x the 10x
rule don't you guys know the 10x rule is
actually the front door
to this secret society to the invisible
rich how did you get into the training
business
i i had a passion for for helping people
when i was a young salesperson and um
i
found that when i had struggles
when i had
droughts
cold spells where i wasn't selling
anything if i would help if i would help
somebody else it it always broke my
drought
so
for some reason it was easier when i
wasn't doing well to help somebody else
to help someone else and it seemed to
break my it's i don't know why why it
worked like that but maybe it's one of
those golden rules about help people you
know the more you give the more you get
and so it always broke this cold moment
i had
when i would reach out and help another
person i was 28 years old three years
sober no drugs in my body for three
years i'm selling cars
i'm moving toyotas
and i'm getting good at it too like you
come in and say look i got bad credit
and i'm not buying today i'm like oh
that's two cars
[Music]
i'ma penalize i'ma penalize you for
saying that boy
okay
okay
yeah bad you got bad credit
that's perfect
at least you got some credit
see i ain't positive i'm there to get
something
so so captain ryan says to me he's like
you're the most positive person i know i
said dude i'm not positive at all
i'm 10x
[Music]
i get results
okay i want to get the deal done i want
to make my kids proud of me
my kids aren't going to remember whether
i was positive or not they're going to
remember whether daddy delivered the
goodies or not
you understand when you go to whole
foods and they say hey that'll be 427
for three bags
and you're like
i got a good attitude
[Music]
they'd be like you need to get some 10x
you need to get some 10x's and money to
go with your freaking attitude
all the greats on this planet were
addicted to something jesus was addicted
he's like hey man i'm going to do
whatever it takes
right or wrong
okay you gotta get addicted to something
good all addictions are not
created equal
okay i'm addicted to my wife
i'm addicted to my kids
i'm addicted to my purpose
i'm addicted to helping out i'm addicted
to making a difference i'm addicted to
doing whatever it takes
to show and be an example of the
blessings that i have
one of the things that we do a little
trick we do at our company
is we always have something on our
calendar to look forward to okay if you
want to stay motivated today's what
sunday
i always have something out here out
here out here out here and out here to
look forward to little short runways
that keep me excited okay i'm going to
turks and caicos to shoot a real estate
uh program when i leave here
yesterday i walked out of here i'm
freaking exhausted i'm like boy i can't
wait to get the turks and caicos see it
re-energizes me
right now when i'm done with that i need
something else to look forward to here i
got a whole bunch of stuff that's going
to happen here at the end of the month
that it's going to keep me jacked up
when i'm at turks and caicos because the
truth is turks and caicos could get a
little boring for a guy like me
how many of you have trouble going on
vacations you have trouble unwinding
okay you don't even want to go you're
like i can't even enjoy this
so i need little tricks i have little
tricks everybody should do this in their
life okay you need things to look
forward to the world you live in today
the cnbc and the cnn and the netflix
[Music]
be happy
just be happy
be satisfied with what you have
there's no push man
there's nobody pushing you
how about this you can do more how many
of you can do more
oh my god if that's all you got how many
of you can do more
oh god damn if you know you can do more
if you know you can do more
then you have to do more
if you know you can help if you know you
can make a difference if you don't
you're going to have this freaking big
big hole inside of you no no amount of
money can fill this thing up
so fill it up for 30 years since i left
that treatment center i have been doing
one thing studying business
i don't need to worry about my neighbor
i don't need to worry about trump i
don't need to worry about obama i don't
need to worry about the democrats i
don't need to worry about anything until
i worry about these 36 inches
man man people like hey do you believe
in aliens dude i got i'm having trouble
with this
all i'm trying to do is expand it over
to here
once i do that maybe i can expand a
little bit but i got to get those six
feet under control
i don't criticize other people i'm too
busy criticizing me
while i work on my life i hope other
people hate on me and criticize me i
love it
it's fuel man i'm like then come on
bring it on
the number one reason you will fail in
this 10x thing
the number one reason businesses fail
is the inability
the inability to sell products in
quantities great enough
and at margins high enough that is the
only reason
you will fail you take too long to go
from the idea
to selling enough products
volume at margins high enough
do that learn to do that
and you can make any dream a reality
okay i want to help the world
this is not taught in schools there's
eight billion people on this planet and
there's no shortage of information how
many have heard this before knowledge is
power
then why are so many people suffering
why are so many people suffering
no it ain't stupid man we have more
information available to us today than
at any time in the history of the world
we got too much information at this
point you got too much information
and not enough action 25 years old i'm
selling automobiles i'm broke i'm in
debt 40 000 in debt
spiritually bankrupt physically bankrupt
hate myself
only thing i had
was an opportunity the car dealer that i
worked for took me back that was an
opportunity
don't
dismiss
the opportunity
you can't go anyplace
without an opportunity no matter how
talented you are no matter how gifted
you are no matter what god has done for
you without an opportunity
you will not
move from your garage
your life cannot improve without an
opportunity it's impossible
you guys don't like sales because you
ain't got any courage
that's why you want to be a you want to
be the vice president of something
that's why you guys want to call it
something else okay most of you in the
room don't even have sales on your card
you you sell real estate for remax okay
or keller and you don't even have sales
on the card you're in network marketing
you refused we don't do sales here
what do you do then okay what do you do
i mean
i think the company's got a financial
statement
you ever read a financial statement
what's the first line on a financial
statement
huh what's that first line it's the
first line by the way
okay i've seen a bunch of income
statements in my life the first the
first ones are like two to maybe max
four inches long big companies big giant
companies okay i got five companies they
run to one financial statement and the
top line the top line the sales line you
could call it i think it's called also
what revenue
could be called gross revenue okay you
know people are getting confused now
they start getting away from this word
some some some college guy came in and
said we can't call it sales man
we got to call it something like at
least two or three words
i mean i went to harvard
it's not about how much money you make
folks
can you use money
can you use it okay look this top these
top lines right here are about income
if you hate sales
you hate income i don't care who you are
i don't care what your age is okay i
spent the first from the age of 25 years
old to 45 years old i spent 20 years
thinking small thinking small and taking
too long i built three little businesses
they were all doing good man they were
doing good three of them man from
scratch
first little business i was a
millionaire when i was 30 33 years old
punching shoving hard work man the more
money i had the more scared i was
because i had just enough money
to be scared
as soon as you get a million dollars
you're going to go into terror
i'm telling you you're gonna be like
what am i gonna do now
okay i wasn't scared before now i got
something to lose
that's why you never want to get your
advice from a millionaire if you're
taking notes never get your advice from
a millionaire ever
okay this held me down for 20 years
20 years it held me down you're looking
at me like huh
i read the millionaire next door
what did the millionaire next door say
buy a used truck and don't go to
starbucks
you say four bucks a day for the next 38
years you're gonna be in heaven no you
ain't you're gonna be stupid
it's dumb man okay if four dollars is
gonna break you on any given day you're
just back to thinking the way you were
thinking when you didn't have anything
buy everything on sale okay everything
you're going to buy is going to be on
sale you got to get a deal every time
you buy something is that what your
daddy taught you never pay retail for
anything that means nobody will ever pay
you retail folks when i was 23 years old
i was beaten within
inches of my life i had 76 stitches put
in my head and face
because i had made nine years of bad
choices
my dad died when i was 10 years old
i think that there's an epidemic in this
country where where families
are missing a father
i know for me i was a good kid i i grew
up in a middle class family my mom and
my dad were very responsible hard
working people
i didn't get beat up there was no
alcoholism there was no drug addiction i
did not get brought up the way kanye
west did
kanye's got excuses i didn't have any
and there's a whole bunch of kids in
america that don't have any excuses but
they don't have
a purpose they don't have an opportunity
and they don't have anything to do
and that was me
when my dad died i was 10 years old and
from 10 to 16 when i should have been
experiencing grief
you know and and and
i was angry about it how many of you had
a loss before and you got angry about it
customer doesn't buy from you god
doesn't show up you get angry
angry is not a response to the situation
and then when somebody sits on anger for
long enough what happens is without a
purpose without a purpose an individual
is going to go away
no matter how good they are they're
going to go off and do other things
and so by the time i was 16 years old i
had a drug problem but by the time i was
20 years old i was using drugs every
single day and by the time i was 23 i
was carrying a gun
every day
worried i was gonna get killed every day
had a college degree 17 years i spent in
school the more mo the more college i
got the less money i had and the more
trouble i ended up in
okay 23 years old i get beat i'm in a
hospital my mom comes to the hospital
she looks at me and says but where's my
son
okay that was me not too long ago it
doesn't seem like it was that long ago
and today legalshield has me to speak to
you today
[Applause]
i i tell you that to tell you like
anybody can come back i don't care how
old you are how young you are what color
you are what your problems are anybody
can come back
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one on one i did
recently with grant check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created investing
elon musk is completely invest
he has no cash and no houses